how I get sober well I had a when my dad
died I was 25 my younger brother had
been 20 and he my brother Steve and he
was a worked in landscape architect as a
laborer and one of his best friends had
a father who was sober named Jack and
when our dad died Stephen moved in with
this guy Jack and there were all these
sober people around his house all the
time talking about how much they loved
being sober in prayer and meditation and
helping others and they they always had
these horrible cakes from Safeway that I
happen to really prefer to good bakery
because I mostly just like the icing and
they also had the swill is terrible
coffee and they're always drinking too
much of this swill late at night whereas
if I drink coffee at night I would sleep
again several days later but so I got to
be friends with this real character
named Jack and he'd been a total lush
like I am and he said you know we're not
drinking one day at a time and
everything that we'd ever dreamt of has
happened for us and I said well I'm very
religious and very spiritual without
your little you know little Safeway
cakes and swill and but I like most
drunks who get gotten sober I got to the
point where I was deteriorating faster
than I could lower my standards you know
so I was getting to a point where I was
living in a way that involved waking up
sick and with a lot of shame and just
kind of animal confusion and one day I
called Jack and said what do I do and he
said when I come over and we'll talk so
that's how I got sober in that side of
states overs people said why don't I
come over and we'll talk and drink our
bad coffee like communion together our
bad coffee and our Safeway cakes
well I became a Christian before I got
sober so I was a drunk bulimic Christian
I wandered into this biracial church
across the highway from where I lived
when I was still drinking very heavily
and using and the only reason I went in
to this church which would happen to be
Presbyterian was because it was across
the street from a flea market and I was
there a lot of Sunday mornings and I was
so hungover and when I'm hungover I'm
drawn to greasy food and lots of it and
then I would hear this gospel singing or
this the songs of the civil rights
movement I grew up my parents were old
lefties I grew up on the weavers and
Pete Seeger and Joan Baez and they would
be singing a lot of the civil rights
anthems and so I'd wander in because I'd
run out of good ideas and and no one at
my church hassled me they're only about
40 people and still are only about 40
people but they didn't try to get me to
sign on the dotted line or tell them who
shot the Holy Ghost they just let me sit
there and they just let me sit there and
the air was nutritious because it was
people who have put their money where
their mouth is and they've done the work
of social justice and they were true
believer and I lived in the Bay Area and
still do in the years of Allen Ginsberg
and Gregory Corso and and Gary Snyder
and Lawrence Ferlinghetti at this
founding city lights and my father loved
the beats and he worked on a magazine
that was very avant-garde in Sanford in
the Bay Area with Evan canal and a
couple of people that were just literary
giants that it was called contact
magazine so I'd always and Alan Watts
was around on these progressive Bay Area
radio stations like KPFA and so I grew
up with the consciousness that
Christianity was for people who were
really stupid but that there was
something magical in the religions of
the east and the Buddhism was okay and
Hindu was okay because Hinduism was okay
because Gere Ginsburg was so wildly
passionately sensuously East in his
understanding of things and so joyous
so and so I've always understood that
meditation had to be poor was part of
the natural path and so I've always sort
of dabbled in it my mate the main
expression of my spirituality has been
this little church I go to
and my sobriety the path of recovery and
the I don't I'm a terrible Christian and
meditating is very hard for me and I do
it I do it badly like I do a lot of
things I believe in doing things badly I
believe in listening to the what calls
you from your heart and your spirit and
if you do it badly like learning to
dance you do it badly or you're going to
kick yourself when you grow old and you
meant to do it